well Marvel obviously put up a good
fight as well there's plenty to get
excited about from there their offerings
first up one of the coolest showings
what I well from my opinion was Doctor
Strange trailer there was definite
inception vibes with the whole earth
pending yeah I thought it was inception
meets sort of matrix e meets quantum
break hmm I mean I'd watched that movie
anyway but it's um like personally I'm
excited to see Marvel jump into the the
realms of the magic and fantastical
we've we've done die agree we've done
superhero teams we've done space and
different galaxies hmm let's throw some
magic about man yeah I think I think
they kind of need to do that now right
with all the stuff that is happening on
netflix and with iron fist and defenders
and that kind of stuff they need to
start exploring more of the other
flavors of the Marvel Universe I think
we can only take so much of the Avengers
lying amongst each other and then
fighting a really weird like one off
yeah one off like oh where the hell did
was that fing Fang Foom but yeah I think
they need to start exploring that stuff
more and I think dr. strange is good
because it's doing that but it's also
kinda like a character study of that
character and kind of his flaws and what
he needs to become the sorcerer supreme
and that kind of stuff so and his bad
American accent yeah like a computer
there and he's amazing magnetic cape did
you see my goodness i need that came i
got up straight away and try to do that
with my coat and just immediately pissed
off my god what i want to know is what
is the difference here to keep and a
cloak I think he's walking a fine line I
think yeah I think a cloak goes over Oh
baby front and the Cape is over your
shoulders just around the back but I
really like the look at trailer yeah
Tilda Swinton obviously it's colorful
hanging on the side of a building ya Yin
is hoppin I'm oh great he looks good I
think he embodies what he's a man
carries himself and from the TV side we
got to learn about dead over season 3
it's happening hopefully better than
season to feast our eyes on the trailer
for luke cage which looked badass that
was excellent choice of music yep that
Jimmy return is an ailing yeah there you
go to shadow yeah just hope they've got
one guy he's got
it's amazing Spotify playlist goes it's
just called wu-tang clan I just scroll
the best of the best of new angle iron
fist looks pretty exciting as well I
will never be able to see him as
anything other than Loras Tyrell was
awful yeah I like I mean they didn't
show much of you know that trailer light
was just hey Danny but then in the
defenders trailer he said there was like
who is Danny R and yeah just like on is
a mystery or the defendants was very was
very teaser did the like the spelling
out the defenders in the kind of ransom
note scholars you are by Nirvana as well
yeah the solid choice and at the end you
hear a stick what sounds like yes him um
mystic obviously was Daredevils ninja
trainer blind dude so that's further
solidifies the group but with won't know
with four heroes stories meeting now I'm
interested to know what the predictions
officers because it's very hard to
balance for massive personalities i
think yeah I think they're gonna I think
that sticks a kind of presents kind of
hints at who they're fighting it's going
to be the hand right and the hand but we
accidentally called working before yeah
free to confuse with a bad guys in
changement is ninja turtles so like and
they're not a kind of like one dude type
group they when they come they come in
force so it's gonna be a lot of them so
I imagine it's gonna be all so that's
all of them oh it's gonna be like the
whole of New York is covered in these
hand dudes so we need to split up and
then they were just get on the phone
which other and the facetime and stuff
as a new good skype logo in the corner
yeah well by you Lucy you excited for
the defenders I'm excited I'm also
interested to see like more heroes I
feel like daredevil season two I wasn't
the biggest fan of there was some bit
like The Punisher was incredible I
absolute loved him but I felt like
daredevil story I want him to meet more
characters like jessica jones i Luke age
yeah sure that and finally we had the
trailer for legion give it to me now
well Lucy's excited for it I wasn't sure
what to think of the teaser but no cuz
I've just come off the bat of watching
fargo and Noah Hawley who's the guy who
brought fire go to TV was Regina movie
by the coen brothers like thats that
show is so Emily really good he's got
some of the same actors from it and he's
got Matthew Crawley from Downton Abbey
dad knowing as the lead guy I'm I mean
well it's on netflix rather than netflix
yeah so it's not exactly clear how we'll
get see in the UK hopefully likely
Netflix yes yeah it follows David hauler
and deals with issues of gotta get dull
haha I get your own TV series that's a
not using wu-tang holla holla get dolla
oh no but it deals with where these
things like schizophrenia mental health
and kind of combines his powers with all
these dealings as well really you know
who he is right he's Xavier son really
yeah we're of that well that stance
makes sense though it's definitely got a
different vibe from what we've seen in
previous here I've got more hair than
difference about 25 different hair
styles but formerly impressions from the
trailer I'm into it I'm anything that's
given me a different vibe and a palate
cleanser from what we've already seen
yeah finally something in the x-men
universe we can get excited about stop
this is too soon I am just quickly then
I have all the marbles offerings what
talks about what we haven't what are you
most excited about Legion and next 18
months coming from a captain marvel oh
god yeah fremont brie Larson yes I was
gonna be rad she's gonna be a week
that's all there was Captain Marvel and
brie Larson same person but I'm on board
with that yeah that's what I'm excited
about I'm aboard captain marvel Legion
and I'm fist and forgotten I'm wu-tang
clan the blue anklet I really like with
anime
you